[Musica]
why why you bello su poster
ciao belli sono andato in live così
completamente a cazzo perché vi devo
raccontare una roba che ho visto vi
giuro su dio e ne ho approfittato per
che dio dove si abita da sempre commenti
sono miss mimì stuprate il telefono ecco
è successo in questo negozio
l'altro giorno vi giuro su dio ieri
praticamente che un tizio si è
praticamente [ __ ] due orsacchiotti
giganti che sono al piano di sopra che
io sono piano di sotto di stato negozio
mega di souvenir si chiama little
britannia un certo punto prende cesto
tizio che c'era una guardiano che stava
guardando l'uscita
io stavo andando verso stata guardia ma
perché stavo guardando le cose non certo
punto questo si mette a correre verso di
me mi scansa la guardia dico e si butta
addosso un tizio che se ne stava uscendo
con due orsacchiotti giganti ha tentato
di rubare è la prima volta che assisto
ad un furto nella mia vita ed è stato io
io ho quasi aiutato la grecia il posto
all'altro ma perché ho proprio niente mi
sono messo davanti alla guardia non la
stavo facendo passare ma se non lo
sapevo cazzola vette che ne so io non mi
prendono come complice in niente vi
faccio questa live direttamente tra
perché vi faccio vedere i due pupazzi in
questione perché fanno troppo ridere
sono piano di sopra e se vi faccio
vedere mentre esco prima di farvi vedere
questo
ciao ciao ciao che più vi faccio vedere
che sei fai vedere questa disgrazia
incredibile come si accende questa cosa
si accende perché no vabbè prima mente
scassato l'iphone e mentre stiamo
andando questa scassato l'iphone si
accende ma rimane così se qualcuno di
voi sa come riparare un iphone così
contattateci perché siamo nella merda
bene e questo qua è l'unico telefono che
abbiamo per rimanere col contatto con la
realtà e al 20 per cento di batteria e
sto facendo uno streaming no bene allora
vi faccio vedere dove questo cazzo di di
orsacchiotto stupido e andiamo di sopra
non so se posso registrare in teoria
quindi
[Musica]
quindi in teoria staro zitto mentre esco
però di spello devo far vedere fa troppo
ridere che ci siamo vi faccio vedere
qual è ecco se nel piano di sopra
io ero qua ero qui
e gli orsacchiotti sono questi
un tipo se li è presi ed è andato verso
l'uscita
fa troppo ridere questa cosa certa è che
a mio padre cosa che cosa si riuscito è
grande stavo facendo la live solo tardi
a casa facciamo una foto dai vieni un
attimo che cela live che sta andando
mite che casino
[Musica]
meglio
vanta c'è una live in porto
poi basta lui
io non ho capito niente
caro vabbè io volevo far vedere la causa
del furto di c'era anche lui ho fatto
vedere alla base del furto di ieri che
hanno rubato le faceva troppo ridere ma
a parti sta stronzata
niente ho io non posso camminare anche a
londra non è possibile allora vi faccio
vedere questa sto facendo uno streaming
rega
dai facciamo la foto viene niente la
guarda guarda di sohari di che sei nel
video per voi che lo vai a screenare
facciamo prima bene poi te lo script ma
anche sette ore quello lo vuole lo vuole
pure lui perché ha fatto sta live
ci penso io nome del web friends matteo
mason doccia leghisti che mi sa che mi
avete fatto a londra challenge sto tizio
marte bis ma siete pazzi
e non è tutto
sta facendo vedere che ha fatto una
challenge domate di questo famoso
red bull ma la vera mente
[Musica]
fish
bene non era questo che volevo fare in
questa live che te perché io faccio i
video e poi li taglio perché quando io
blogo succedono ste cose sempre sempre
su 106 io taglio tutto perché succedono
sempre ste robe sempre
vabbè vabbè allora volevo dirvi altra
roba in questo blog abbiamo praticamente
fatto vedere l'iphone rotto ma non è
solo l'unica roba rotta
a parte il cazzo anche quello si è rotto
non so se conoscete piccadilly circus è
famosa perché c'è quella specie di
televisore gigante pieno di spot quel
palazzo pieno di spot pubblicitari e che
sarebbe questo il problema è che non
l'ho mai vista in vita mia spento è
spento per otto perché la nostra che
l'hanno spinto a non so proprio perché
quando ci sono io le cose non vanno poi
capitan allora volevo fare una live sul
london eye oggi hop e sarai la devo fare
sull'online non l'ho fatta perché london
eye è in disuso c'è l'essenza lo stanno
rimodernare non so che cazzo stato 140
quindi non ho potuto fare la live
ha sconvolto hanno fatto qua perché
londra e non va non va neanche questo
non fa un cazzo
faccio la live in giro a lecce ci sono i
fan a londra
se c'è quello che faccio è lecito ma
temi che quindi niente non posso farle
line tranquillo prima che li mettano il
copyright e lo attraversa la strada
porca [ __ ] ci sarà musica quando ti
faccio vedere prima di andare
il padre miskov line vi faccio vedere
prima di andare di spegnere sola punta
se riesco a ritrovare per qualche strano
motivo il teatro di harry potter perché
l'altro giorno io a caso completamente a
caso camminando sono arrivato ciao ciao
valutate prima
ciao treni dei capelli album belli con i
miei
certo ci mancherebbe
io intanto continuo a parlare che ha
praticamente vabbè se sei pronta
facciamo
[Musica]
da ora praticamente mentre camminavo
completamente a caso l'altro giorno qua
su questa via qui che vedete che non c'è
non c'è un cazzo non c'è il proprio in
caso di saviano negozi e vabè mcdonald
faccio tutto giro l'angolo a caso e ciò
davanti il teatro quello dove hanno
fatto l'ultimo capitolo di harry potter
l'ultimo capitolo hanno fatto in
quest'altro lì è stato fighissimo cio
camminavo girava girato a un certo punto
l'angolo così
cosa perché tanto una sala schiantandosi
di mera prefetto vabbè c'è londra e ti
stupisce per cos'è a caso va beh
comunque per quanto riguarda il reporter
è qua vi dico questa cosa domani domani
sarò ai warner studios come casti
chiamano quelli dove ci sono dove c'è
dove hanno ricostruito tutto il set di
harry potter sahrawi london studios
quindi domani vado in live come sto
facendo oggi ai agli studios di harry
potter
ok quindi preparatevi perché domani i
ragazzi ci sarà la live di tutte le live
come la madre di tutte le live perché
minchia sul set di a non so neanche se
posso farlo se non lo posso fare sarà
ancora un video migliore cazzo se non la
potrò fare sono ancora meglio perché
sarà tutto un cercare di farla senza
farmi vedere sarà fichissimo e quindi
domani faccio anche quello se se riesco
ma riuscirò per forza quindi non non per
le tree quella di domani quella di oggi
era improvvisata vi ripeto dovevo andare
sul london eye ma non so perché non lo
sta non funziona oggi non va a porca
[ __ ] e quindi niente l'ho fatto in
mezzo a tutti fantastico allora si
riesca ad arrivare al teatro del
reporter prima di morire
e meglio perché io non riesco a parlare
a camminare non so resistenza porca
[ __ ] allora passiamo a no perché mentre
vi parlo io mi sto perdendo ci sta che
stia andando chissà dove non puoi non
poi mi perdono subito che stiamo andando
allora siamo
re cazzo simbolo dunque ragazzi e pieno
di c'è veramente ci sono più italiani
qua che in italia è pazzesco sonoramente
più italiani poche in italia incredibile
io quando sono andate ad amsterdam ho
visto un miliardo e mezzo di italiani
e la cosa mi sembra la strana ma qui qui
a londra raga e pieno pieno di italiani
incredibile bellissimo questa è una
delle strade vicino a piccadilly che è
una delle strade più conosciute no
ricadi nintendo ci sono appunto i
turisti negozi la metà sono italiani
è incredibile ora che cazz e globali
cos'è cos'è sta roba eh vabbè chinatown
no vabbè che figata
vorrei fermarmi ma non posso devo farvi
vedere tanto le di harry potter
quindi proseguiamo mi spiace ragazzi
riporta il prima di tutto non esiste
altro allora italiano
la bella italia non so se si legge
italiano tutti italiani tutti tutti
nicchia incredibile
allora comunque siccome dai fondi della
mia amica si è rotto quello di mio padre
ovviamente ha un telefono del 1800
l'unico telefono funzionante e questo
con il quale sto facendo la live e al 10
per cento di batteria quindi se si
scarica sta roba
siamo nella merda però io ci sto facendo
una live che spreca giusto un po di
batteria
siamo praticamente arrivati l'ultima
roba che vi voglio dire che mi avete
chiesto tutti dovete detto farvi è bella
la live funziona tutto perché sto
facendo dei test per chi non lo sapesse
queste live sono dei test per vedere se
funzionano
quante [ __ ] st via fonte [ __ ] quanto
bello gli rubò tutti quei cosi li voglia
il mio compleanno appeso in casa vorrei
roba fighissimo comunque volevo dirvi
per chi non lo sapesse questa beta
testing delle live cioè io sto testando
la funzione live il conto di youtube e
me l'ha chiesto
quindi ci sono delle cose che magari non
funzionano ad esempio si vede ogni tanto
pixellato è normale perché la salva
ancora rifinendo st up mi ha detto
youtube che miglioreranno però io sono
il tester e quindi loro dalle mie live
vedono che cosa non va quindi è normale
che ci siano questi problemi sarà anche
la connessione poiché cazzo ne so io per
fare questa lei ho dovuto farmi una sim
londinese con vodafone tra l'altro che
qua in inghilterra non so perché non
prende un cazzo
qui prende qui prende prendo un cazzo
non prende cazzo prende bruce che cazzo
prendi prendi un cazzo non prendi
comunque in italia l'amor di dio non lo
so però qua in inviterà prende poco poi
va bene
per quello ho paura di fare la live sul
london eye ma devono mettere questi cosi
anche dentro i costi dei pompieri
niente tutto china si capisce perché più
anche dentro il meccanico ci sono i casi
dei cc sono incazzati ma corro corro mi
seguono
siamo arrivati laga siamo in teoria
arrivati se non vi sono perso perché è
possibile che io mi sia perso non mi sa
che questo ci siamo io fa un freddo
found se voi in italia pensate di avere
freddo non avete freddo il confronto vi
giuro su dio fa un freddo incredibile io
voi che son magro babel a sean penn
ma porca [ __ ] lasciate stare la
connessione è debole mi dicono qui dice
youtube grazie al cup grazie vodafone
grazie blues che non prendi qui non
prende ci siamo ragazzi meno male che la
connessione debole verso la fine
endemico quello dell'altro ieri il
governo
eccolo riuscivo a inquadrarlo quello del
teatro di harry potter
se riesco ad andarci davanti magari
riesco chiuderebbe nel video
di farci il mestire i dismessi raiola
violo jolo
ho provato
fatemi passare sono in live non mi fanno
passare
ciao bello fa mi chiude fammi cure e
live streaming fammi chiuderla live
aspetta aspetta che qui non prendi
signori signori siamo arrivati all
teatro è fighissimo e bellissimo mi sono
fatto 10.000 senti qua domani cercherò
di essere in live al sul set di harry
potter vi aspetto tutti lì vi mando un
bacio grande ci sentiamo civilian domani
bella